bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord ces
milliers de manifestants qui sont à
alger pour le deuxième anniversaire du
irak
que faut-il attendre de cette journée
particulière
oui aujourd'hui donc les algériens ont
comme on observe depuis ce matin il ya
une forte mobilisation pour célébrer le
deuxième anniversaire du il ya cette
forte mobilisation bien sûr révèle le
fait que les algériens ne décolère pas
que la détermination des algériens pour
continuer à protester se poursuit malgré
la suspension des manifestations
hebdomadaires
suite à la crise sanitaire comme on le
sait donc aujourd'hui il ya où il ya
cette mobilisation montre également qui
fit suite bien sûr au taux d'abstention
très bas lors du référendum de novembre
dernier montré également que la
politique de la politique qui a été
poursuivie après nom et quelques mois de
la présidentielle gones ne suffit pas ne
suffit pas pour apaiser les tensions
pour aux yeux des algériens n'en porte
pas n'apporte pas la transition
souhaitée et n'apporte pas une réponse à
nos revendications tant attendu par
beaucoup d'algériens aujourd'hui à
parvenir sur justement la présidence
teboul mais deux ans après sa création
qu'elle quelles sont les revendications
du mouvement du irak est ce que ces
revendications ont changé et est ce que
ce mouvement il est mieux structuré
les revendications à ce que les mêmes
sont trop milieux politiques on l'entend
selon d'entrée tous les slogans répétés
à travers les différentes régions
différents willaya dans le pays qui sont
d'abord un changement politique dans les
transitions politiques ne départs des
figures du système comme seconde
différents manifestons donc restent les
mêmes depuis le premier jour du créac'h
donc avec le qui a déclenché le débat
qui a poussé le départ de bouteflika
aujourd'hui le contexte n'a pas beaucoup
changé sur notamment la nada qu'ils
économique bien sûr la scène crise
politique bien sûr s'ajoute la crise
économique
je dirais on qui finit par des snuff qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup d'algériens
s'inquiète de la situation de leur
situation et aussi de la situation du
pays et qui considèrent avec avec la
prise et dont stone que rien n'a changé
bien sûr les arrestations à répétition
en tout cas et plusieurs mois des
manifestions de journalistes même si
certains ont été libérés récemment la
semaine dernière est un critère pour
beaucoup que le système reste le même on
a changé de gouvernement mais on n'a pas
changé concrètement le système politique
algérien précisé que le président actuel
abdel mahdi de thé boon a passé trois
mois en allemagne où il s'est fait
soigner pour des complications post
coheed il est rentré au pays il a tenté
un peu de désamorcer la situation
les tensions en promettant donc en rhum
avec un remaniement ministériel la
libération vous l'avez dit de
prisonniers mais aussi la promesse du
coup de législatives anticipées
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour calmer
rue pour le moment le président fera
bien sûr une issue électorale à la crise
politique est un disciple bien sûr on
anticipe canada la colère d'aujourd'hui
le retour en tout cas de la mobilisation
comme observe aujourd'hui mais ce ne
sera pas je pense pas que ce soit
suffisant
je rappelle que la liberté de certains
prisonniers ne cache pas pour beaucoup
d'algériens le fait que de dix ans
d'autres restent encore on présent de
prison lyne politique bien sûr et la
dissolution du parlement bien sûr offre
une lune et sue crise mais faut-il que
l'idée région actuelle puisse puisse
convaincre les algériens que ces
élections apporteront réellement un
changement au système parce que comme on
a vu dans le passé
la crise de confiance qui est très
importante la confiance l'image des
régions en algérie très abîmé les
algériens ont perdu confiance après
plusieurs provinces plusieurs années
plusieurs décennies même de promesses
non tenues sous bouteflika mais aussi
aujourd'hui tout cela participe à la
déception des algériens vous l'avez dit
l'hospitalisation nom bien à l'étranger
du président algérien
les hospitalisations la station sont au
k2 de dieu de l'ancien président montage
l'écart
mansur l'armée juste pour terminer
rapidement être que l'armée continue de
tirer les ficelles du pays
je ne dirais pas l'armée mais certains
dirigeants certains chefs de l'armée
bien sûr qui est un défi sel sont encore
très influents sont très influents et
pour des raisons multiples ne lâche pas
bien sûr on ne lâche pas la sphère
politique au point les tic
il ya sans contribuer ça contribue
également à la crise actuelle il faut
qu'il y est il faut instaurer une fois
que les dirigeants actuels algérien on
le paie le pays a besoin d'instaurer un
climat de confiance
inclure un climat de confiance pour
sortir le pays de cette crise et je
rappelle quand même que la situation est
très très très très explosive pour pour
la neige des rires en congé pour la peau
pour le les multiples et crise bien sûr
qu'ils vont grains de pays l'économie
qui les politiques et sociales
l'inflation les algériens souffrent
aujourd'hui de l'inflation d'autres
produits merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris